es gibt ziemlich viele krankheiten und
schädlinge die einem den garten spaß
gründlich vermiesen können und die
einfachste und natürlichste methode dem
entgegenzuwirken ist eine gute
fruchtfolge deswegen möchte ich euch in
diesem video erklären wie ihr eine
fruchtfolge erstellt falls ihr mich noch
nicht kennt ich bin marie ich mache
videos und um das thema selbstversorgung
aus dem garten abonniert gerne meinen
kanal und drückt doch die glocke damit
ihr informiert wird wenn ich neue videos
posten
jetzt sprechen wir erst mal über die
fruchtfolge was ist das überhaupt falls
du dich mit dem thema anbauplanung wirst
du gar nicht auskennst schaue erst mal
mein an bauplanungs video das verlinkt
ich mal hier oben wo ich die ganzen
grundlagen darlege und jetzt zeige was
wirklich wichtig ist wenn du an deinem
an bauplan sitzt die fruchtfolge ist ein
teil der anbauplanung dient genauso wie
die mischkultur genauso wie die
gestaffelte ernte und so weiter da
erfährst du einfach erst mal wie du das
thema anbau plan gehen kannst und wenn
du dann bei der fruchtfolge angekommen
bist dann ist das hier das richtige
video für dich sprechen wir also über
schädlinge und krankheiten die meisten
schädlinge und krankheiten sind genau
auf ihr lieblings gemüse spezialisiert
also die befallen eine pflanze oder eine
pflanzenfamilie immer immer wieder und
wenn du jedes jahr wieder auf dem selben
weg genau dieses lied nix gemüseanbaus
ein tisch zu denen ja genau das was sie
haben wollen und so können sich dann
schädlinge und krankheiten super einfach
in deinem garten verbreiten
so fallen jedes jahr wieder die pflanzen
und setzten sich in deinem daten fest
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass du das
ganze rotiert und auf den beeten immer
wieder andere gemüse anbauen oder jedes
jahr eine neue ganzen familie drauf an
was ein weiterer zum warum prof wichtig
sind ist die nährstoffversorgung der
pflanzen es gibt ja stark sera also sehr
hungrige gemüse wie viel jünger oder
nährstoffe brauchen
es gibt mittel cera die hütte viel
brauchen und das gebiet schwach zu ihrer
die pflanzen wenig und wenn du in einem
beet im ersten jahr stark zähler anbaus
und der dünger ladung verpasst dann ist
im nächsten jahr noch genug von diesen
nährstoffen übrig für die mittel cera
und im dritten jahr kannst du dann
darauf schwarz der anbau und so nutzt
werden auch noch die nährstoffe sehr
sinnvoll in deinem garten ich finde das
aber immer so ein bisschen zweitrangig
weil im zweifel kann man immer einfach
nur ein bisschen mehr düngen wenn man
doch dann wieder stark zur erstattung
schwarz ihrer anbauen möchte deswegen
acht ich zwar schon auf die
nährstoffzusammensetzung den
nährstoffbedarf der pflanzen aber in
erster linie achte ich auf die pflanzen
familien weil das nämlich dabei hilft
die schädlinge und krankheiten und
auszuhungern es gibt pflanzen familien
die sehr hartnäckige schädigen und
krankheiten haben zum beispiel die
kreuzblütler also alle cool gewächse und
die liegen mir nur sind als in erbsen
und bohnen zum beispiel
und da ist es eben ganz wichtig dass man
daten wirklich darauf achten anlauf
pause einzuhalten ich kann euch gerne
mal eine tabelle mit den anbau pausen
und den pflanzen familien hier unter dem
video verlinken so dass ihr nach stunden
könnt welche gemüse gehören dann
überhaupt zu welcher pflanzenfamilie und
wie lang ist da die anbau pause also den
link packe ich euch gerne hier unter das
video so dass ihr euch das mal anschauen
könnt dann wahrlich eben meinen garten
plan auf also ich zeichne alle umrisse
einer beete und dann muss ich da so ein
bisschen rum und stelle das so zusammen
dass ich wirklich alle anbau pausen
einhalten also wenn ich jetzt ein beet
mit kohl gepflanzten will dann weiß ich
die anbau pause sollte fünf bis sechs
jahre betragen also kann ich nur auf
jedes fünfte bis sechste überhaupt
kohlpflanzen damit es dann rotieren kann
also jedes jahr die meta einfach um
einen platz weiter verschoben werden und
dann erst nach fünf oder sechs jahren
das bild wieder auf demselben beet
ankommt also das lag wohl wieder auf
demselben bild angebaut wird so dass da
wirklich eine gute pause dazwischen gibt
und so persönlich das dann hin und her
mit dieser tabelle mit dem
pflanzenfamilien so dass ich genau
einteilen kann welche gemüse auf welchem
weg wachsen und widerstand rotiert und
wenn man das einmal festgelegt hat denn
es ist auch gar nicht mehr schwer in den
folgenden jahren den anbau plan zu
erstellen weil du den beim jassen hast
dann kannst du das einfach immer um
einen platz verschieben ich mache immer
noch ein paar kleine anpassungen jedes
jahr wenn ich gemerkt haben wir doch ein
bisschen zu wenig sagen davon will ich
mehr pflanzen
ich habe lust ergebnisse an zu bauen wo
kombinieren und so weiter aber das
grundgerüst steht und das ist ein super
für alle von euch denen das zu
kompliziert ist habe ich einen fertigen
an bauplan entsteht gegen ihr euch gerne
runterladen können den link hab ich euch
auch hier unser das video der ist
kostenlos da könnt ihr euch einfach
inspirieren lassen oder ihr könnt den
auf eins zu eins auf euren garten
übertragen da etwas falsch und
ausgeklügelt auf die sache mit der
mischkultur das video ist übrigens hier
verlinkt so dass ja ihr euch da wirklich
keine gedanken mehr machen als machtlos
leer dann können weil ich weiß dass das
schon ziemlich viel kopfzerbrechen
bereiten kann wenn man so mögen und
anbau plan erstellen will und wirklich
alles beachten möchte also ladet euch
den klaren gerne herunter ich freue mich
über eure kommentare also erzählt mal
wie weit ihr mit eurem an bauplan
gekommen seid erzählt mal welche
mischkulturen ihr gerne verwendet wie
ihr das mit der fruchtfolge macht achtet
ihr das oder dass ich egal was habt ihr
dafür erfahrungen gemacht abonniert auch
gerne den kanal werde mehr zum thema
gemüsegarten anbauplanung hühnerhaltung
haltbarmachen der ernte selbstversorgung
erfahren möchte tim auch die glocke
drücken bei youtube euch nur dann
bescheid sagt wenn ihr die glocke
gedrückt habt und selbst dann manchmal
nicht so wie ich das verstanden habe wie
auch immer glocke drücken ist
anscheinend sehr wichtig gibt mir den
daumen nach oben oder einen daumen nach
unten nicht in dem auto gefallen hat ich
freue mich von euch zwei jahren macht
gut wir sehen uns nächste woche wieder
zu